si mon chat collègues la parole est à
monsieur bernard fourni à madame la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
monsieur le président madame le ministre
mes chers collègues je souhaite vivement
attirer votre attention et celle du
gouvernement sur la reconnaissance de la
formation des orthophonistes au grade
master initiée dans le cadre de la
refonte des études universitaires sur
trois niveaux licence master doctorat
impulsée par le processus de bologne en
1999 voici quatorze ans la réforme lmd
implique la modification du système
d'enseignement supérieur français en vue
de la création de l'espace européen de
l'enseignement supérieur comme vous le
savez les orthophonistes sont des
acteurs de santé aux compétences
spécifiques ayant pour mission de
réduire ou de pallier les troubles et
l'impact des handicaps de communication
à tous les âges de la vie aujourd'hui
n'ayons pas peur des mots la qualité des
soins apportés par ces professionnels
est menacée en effet et c'est une
certitude présent seule une formation
initiale au niveau master peu répond aux
compétences définies par le ministère de
la santé pour exercer la profession
d'orthophoniste en outre le master est
le garant d'une orthophonie de qualité
pour tous les patients sur tout le
territoire d'ailleurs je tiens à vous
rappeler que le ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche a proposé le 31 mars 2011
l'éligibilité du diplôme d'orthophonie
au grade master je sais que cette
reconnaissance repose très clairement
sur des éléments objectifs avec le
soutien des représentants des
professionnels des confédérations
syndicales des étudiants des chercheurs
des centres de formation de plus je vous
confirme que l'ensemble des composantes
de la profession fortement investi ces
dernières années pour répondre aux
attentes pédagogique exigé par la
réforme du système lmd attend maintenant
que le gouvernement officialise cette
poule mission enfin le président de la
république monsieur françois hollande
alors député de corrèze et candidat du
parti socialiste à l'élection
présidentielle
considéré comme légitime la demande
d'une reconnaissance par le ministère de
la santé d'une formation initiale au
grade master pour la profession
d'orthophoniste il s'était engagé à
soutenir la position de cette profession
sur ce dossier
malheureusement aujourd'hui le dossier
de la réforme des études d'orthophonie
n'est toujours pas traitées et ce malgré
le soutien de nombreux parlementaires
qui se sont déjà fait l'écho de cette
juste demande il faut désormais agir en
conséquence je souhaite connaître les
mesures que vous envisagez de prendre en
la matière afin de faire rapidement
évoluer les choses je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue par l'état
madame michèle delaunay millischer et
des personnes âgées de l'autonomie
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur fournier
une fois encore permettez-moi des fusées
madame la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche qui
barillet de la représenter pour vous
témoigner j'passe de l'engagement de
notre gouvernement dans ce dossier vous
êtes vous l'interrogez en effet sur la
reconnaissance du grade de master de la
formation de rejouer comme vous le savez
ce sujet occupe une place importante
dans l'actualité les travaux de réagir
défi de la formation me dante au
certificat de capacité d'orthophonistes
visant l'inscription de cette formation
dans le schéma licence master doctorat
sont en cours de finalisation
le groupe de travail réunissant des
professeurs d'université des formateurs
d'orthophonie des professionnels et des
représentants étudiants conduit par les
conseillers scientifiques de la
direction générale pour l'enseignement
supérieur et l'insertion
professionnelle est chargé d'élaborer le
nouveau référentiel de formation
qui sera achevée incessamment au début
de l'année 2013 la construction de ce
référentiel de formation
s'appuie sur les référentiels d'activité
de compétences transmis par la direction
générale de l'offre de soins du
ministère des affaires sociales et de la
santé sur la base de ce référentiel de
formation
le niveau de reconnaissance de la
formation sera déterminé en accord avec
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
et la ministre des affaires sociales et
de la santé la mise en oeuvre du
référentiel de la formation nécessite au
préalable
l'élaboration d'une nouvelle
réglementation relative aux diplômes
sanctionnant les études d'orthophonie
puis une campane d'habilitation des
universités souhaitant délivrer ce
diplôme le projet de texte relatif à la
formation
résilié menanteau certificat de capacité
d'orthophonie est présenté au conseil de
national de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche dès ce début d'année
2013 des nouvelles donc qui je l'espère
vous satisfait merci monsieur fournier
oui eh bien madame la ministre je
voudrais vous remercier pour la réponse
assez précise que vous m'avez apporté
j'ai noté que et bien ce qui vous était
demandée allait pouvoir se concrétiser
dans les semaines qui viennent puisque
vous parliez de début d'année 2013 nous
voilà
satisfait de votre réponse mais en
attendant nous serons très vigilants
tout cas je vous remercie